[Musique]
bonjour claude blanchemaison ravi de
vous retrouver dans la matinale d'air
france cet accord entre l'iowa et l'iran
est ce que c'est un premier pas selon
vous
oui c'est un bon signal puisque le
directeur général de l'aïe va s'était
rendu pendant le week-end dernier à
téhéran et qu'il a réussi à conclure un
accord avec le gouvernement iranien pour
prolonger pendant trois mois la
possibilité des inspections de l'aiea
il a reconnu que ces inspections ne
serait peut-être pas aussi complète que
les précédentes puisqu'il ya cette
fameuse position du parlement iranien
qui voulait dans le fond se débarrasser
complètement des inspecteurs de l'aiea
mais qui va en restreindre l'activité
on a vu d'ailleurs que le parlement et
rania a mal réagi à cet accord dimanche
soir puisque dans le fond il considère
que ce sont les modérés qui l'ont
emporté avec cet accord et qu' ils ont
indiqué dans leur mauvaise humeur que il
ne voterait pas le budget de l'iran qui
doit être votée normalement avant le 21
mars donc ceux ci dégage un espace de
négociation pendant trois mois au
maximum entre les etats-unis et l'iran
pour voir dans quelles conditions les
deux pays peuvent rentrer dans l'accord
c'est à dire les états unis lever les
sanctions et l'iran à appliquer
pleinement toutes les dispositions de
l'accord les deux parties ont accepté
que ceci se passe un petit peu sous la
houlette de l'union européenne et en
présence des autres participants à
l'accord c'est à dire la france la
grande bretagne l'allemagne la russie et
la chine
et ceci est un acquis puisque tous ces
pays sont des partisans de l'accord
le président américain joe biden lui est
il libre de conclure cet accord
nucléaire avec l'iran
alors évidemment il est un petit peu
gêné aux entournures par ce que il veut
rejoindre cet accord mais vous avez
entendu tout à l'heure le secrétaire
d'état clinton qui blinken qui évoque
trois sujets collatéraux mais qui sont
peut-être lié au retour des américains
regardent à l'accord 1 qu'est ce qui se
passe à partir de 2025
2 pourrait-on parler de la prolifération
balistique et 3 pourrait-on parler de
l'action des milices iraniennes en irak
en syrie et au liban
alors les villes lévirat n'y avons bien
dit retour à l'accord d'accord mais à
l'accord tel qu'il est c'est à dire
celle qui a été conclue le 15 juillet
et pas question d'ajouter d'autres
éléments d'ailleurs le 15 juillet 2015
il avait été conclu dans l'état où il
est parti n'était pas possible d'aller
plus loin il n'est pas possible d'y
inclure le balistique iranien elle
refusait n'était pas possible de prévoir
ce qui se passerait après 2025 là aussi
l'iran le refuser il n'est pas possible
non plus de parler de façon
opérationnelle du rôle des milices
iraniennes au proche orient alors toute
la question va tourner autour de cela
c'est à dire est ce que les américains
acceptent de dissocier ces trois sujets
de leur retour dans l'accord
est ce que les iraniens de leur côté
accepte d'ouvrir une négociation sur ces
sujets sans que ce soit évidemment à
condition des américains le disent aussi
strictement du retour à l'accord alors
on voit bien que l'union européenne a un
peu un rôle un rôle de médiateur a joué
les russes et les chinois d'ailleurs
également est-ce que
joe boyd est totalement libre il va
avoir beaucoup de problèmes avec le
gouvernement netanyahu qui considère que
cet accord du 15 juillet 2015 est un
accord épouvantable qui le met en danger
la sécurité le d'israël et il est
probable que le gouvernement israélien
va développer cette tél d'autant plus
qu'il est à la veille des élections
puisque au mois de mars il doit y avoir
des élections législatives en israël
les autres signataires claude les autres
signataires de l'accord comme les russes
les chinois ou bien et les européens
ont-ils un rôle à jouer
justement dans cet accord oui ils ont un
rôle très important et un rôle de
facilitateur pour eux il est très
important que les américains reviennent
dans cet accord puisque eux n'en sont
jamais sortis mais il est clair que sans
les américains il est difficile
d'appliquer l'accord puisque les
américains étendent leur sanction de
façon extraterritoriale et qu'il était
prêt à sanctionner toutes les
entreprises et qui travaillerait avec
l'iran ça d'ailleurs eu un effet
important puisque la plupart des
entreprises d'europe occidentale se sont
désengagés en iran que les banques
également se sont désengagés et
l'économie iranienne en a subi les
conséquences l'économie indienne est
aujourd'hui dans une situation très très
très très grave très très près des
primes et la monnaie iranienne a fondu
il y a est un produit qui manque sur le
marché iranien et ceci pour comble de
malheur pour les pauvres aux iraniens se
combine avec les effets de la pandémie
due que vides pour lesquelles les
iraniens sont à la recherche de lac
sainte
la russie a promis d'en fournir un
certain nombre
la chine aussi peut-être y aura-t-il
d'ailleurs dans les mois qui viennent un
vaccin d'iraniens merci beaucoup que
l'ogm ans maison pour votre analyse on
vous retrouve évidemment lundi prochain
pour l édito de politique internationale
merci